toutes les nuits
je fais le même marque
et ensuite
le cauchemar commence
j'ai fait ce que je devais faire
[Musique]
pour protéger notre monde tu ne peux pas
tout contrôler et strange
tu as ouvert un portail entre les
univers
c'est pas quel set où quelque chose ne
franchiront
que sais tu à propos du multivers vision
avait une théorie
il pensait que c'était dangereux
il avait raison
je suis désolé stephen
cette profanation de la réalité
ne restera pas impuni
[Musique]
nous devrions lui dire la vérité
on dirait que tu as perdu le contrôle
[Musique]
rien
tu deviens un héros
quand je le fais je deviens l'ennemi
je trouve pas ça normal
[Musique]